good morning believe nation today's
message is manage yourself over to
youkai green the achievement way things
don't comes from you know the ability to
manage yourself very very very well you
know or at least well enough where you
almost become compulsive about getting
certain things done you know you'll have
to set a standard for yourself that it's
very very very high you know and you
have to manage yourself to keep your
thoughts where they need to be in order
to allow you to be successful at what
you're trying to do one way you can say
absolutely I can is not with your mouth
but with your actions and actions of the
product of thought so if you're
continuing to think like I was saying
when we were training am I doing this as
as as good as I can can I command more
for myself am I am i connecting with
this muscle was as intensely as I can
can am i training hard enough you know
can I train harder
this is a really important message for
entrepreneurs especially because as an
entrepreneur you don't have anybody
pushing you to do better right if you're
working in a typical job you have a boss
if you don't show up on time if you
don't get the project done on time if
you're slacking off you're gonna hear it
you're gonna hear from it right you're
gonna have somebody breathing fire down
your neck to say get this thing done or
you're gonna be fired and so because you
have that external pressure you're much
more likely to go and achieve the goals
where as entrepreneurs yes we are
ultimately responsible to our customers
and if we commit to them to do something
we're probably gonna do it but at the
end of the day a lot of times we're not
responsible to anybody else right
nobody's really tracking what time you
get up how many hours you work how late
it goes if you're really putting your
all into that project it just kind of
mailing it in nobody's really on you
to get better nobody's really pushing
you to get better and the people who
have the most success as entrepreneurs
are the ones who can manage themselves
and push themselves and have higher
standards of excellence for themselves
than anybody puts on them but you want
this product to be amazing more than
your customer wants a product to be
amazing that you care more about solving
the customers problem than they care
about solving the problem you have to
have that level of pride and expectation
on yourself
to push yourself otherwise you won't
follow through I think back to when I
was in school and my parents always
expected me to get aced my sister's
always got A's and I was always getting
B's and C's and I always had to have
that conversation every report card time
to talk about why I wasn't getting A's
and it was always in a very positive
encouraging way I always left with them
telling me that I was Evan Carmichael
everything cuz truely Carmichael I could
do anything that I wanted and that they
believed that I could go out and do it
and something happened in my last year
of high school where in the year before
that I was getting my B's and C's and in
my last year high school something
tweaked and I don't know what it was and
I might have to go into like some deep
dive psycho analytics to figure it out
but my own expectations
suddenly surpassed what my parents
expected of me and so in my last year of
high school I got straight 90s I didn't
just get A's which is what all they were
asking for I got straight 90s I had a
higher standard than anybody else put on
me and it's still the same today no
matter what you guys think of the videos
however critical you may be however you
might like them my own standards for the
videos are higher than what you guys
have for me I want them to be better
more than you want them to be better
everything that I'm working on
I have insane high standards for much
more than anybody else's expectations on
me and I think you need to develop that
in your life in your business to grow
and accomplish those big dreams because
if you're always waiting for somebody
else to push you to get something done
if you need to be micromanaged
constantly by somebody else before
you're gonna take action then you're
always going to be subject to other
people's expectations instead of you
going out and building the business and
the
that you want so the question that today
is how effective are you at managing
yourself and what gets in the way super
curious to find out please leave in the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot I'm interested